welcome back we are going to go right
back to the phones at six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty and
see what is on people's minds let's go
to our caller from the eight one five
area code who's calling today from eight
one five yes it is hi all right so I
kind of have a two-part question here
you're no doubt familiar with basically
how the all right pipeline worked a few
years ago like I've even seen you do
videos on it yep do you think something
is you know something similar is
happening in the opposite direction and
I don't mean like the conservative idea
of anything even remotely forgotten a
socialist that means do you think
there's now currently a similar pipeline
that is turning people into actual
socialist actual communist well what the
thing about calling it a pipeline I mean
so listen there are people that go into
and come out of a political ideology all
the time there are people that become
outright and people that stop being all
right all right there are people that
become socialists and who stopped being
socialists etc that's normal the
question about calling it a pipeline to
me is more one about is there a
particular path that we can identify
that is either happening through like
proactive propaganda movements or
indoctrination movements disinformation
or simply like algorithms online I mean
I'm open to the idea that there is
something similar going on with
socialism I'm just I'm just not aware of
it I mean certainly there's socialist
voices on websites like YouTube and
Reddit and Twitter and you can certainly
create an echo chamber for yourself of
socialist voices whether there's a
pipeline per se I don't I guess I don't
have enough information to say like what
do you have in mind what do you identify
as that pipeline
well the biggest pieces of evidence of
this in my opinion are the rise of a lot
of popular overtly socialist content
online like there's tons of socialist
youtubers out there with
it's not hundreds of thousands of subs
it's basically just blowing up online
and the second part of this question
would be do you think this is a good or
bad thing for the last in America well
there's two that they depend so I am NOT
a socialist so if the question is do I
think the Democratic Party needs to
start running on socialism my personal
answer is no but that's not happening if
the question is are we better off if
more people are exposed to the ideas of
socialism and understand them for what
they are rather than the cartoonist
cartoon afid things that the right likes
to say I'm all for that yeah okay yeah
yeah yeah no I listen I took Marxian
economics at the University of
Massachusetts as an undergraduate my
professors there were Richard Wolff the
socialist economist and the late Steve
Resnick and it was one of the few
schools that was actually offering as
part of their Economics Department
serious classes on Marxian economics and
I'm better for it it didn't turn me into
a socialist but I now understand some
about those ideas I think that's great
socialism okay but I think the spreading
of these socialist ideas online is
causing a lot of people on the left to
act in ways that are kind of
counterproductive like for example I'm
actually in a few socialist discord of a
few of the bigger socialist content
creators yeah and it's a very common
narrative there that basically electoral
ISM is dead there's no point in
participating in this election the only
way we're going to get real change like
this we take direct action outside of
the system don't bother voting for Biden
and it won't matter okay so let me let
me address that so here's the thing
every movement is going to create some
very loud people who will turn what
you're describing is accelerate
it's basically like working within the
system no longer works you need to
destroy the system that's not unique to
socialism right I mean we've the Tea
Party extremists also had a component of
acceleration ax stuff about ways in
which society needs to be broken down
and sort of like rebuilt white
supremacists fundamentally are talking
about you know significantly
acceleration estai Diaz and in many I
don't I think it would be unfair to say
that that's unique to socialism there
are certainly people who start following
socialist
theory learning about it and they end up
in the pier talking about that's not
most of them and I don't think that that
is the we could say that that's unique
to socialism I don't think we need to be
more worried about extremist socialists
than we need to be worried about
extremist libertarians or extreme you
know whatever I think that at the
extremes of most movements you will find
people whose ideas are very unlikely to
ever really be mainstreamed and to put
too much emphasis on them probably
probably doesn't make sense listen I
appreciate the call I I do want to move
on because I've got some other people
that want to get on here but very
important topics for sure let's go to
our caller from the six seven eight area
code who's calling today from six seven
eight six seven eight hey how are you
who's this hey max what's up seemingly
Republican states red states are doping
up rather fast and it seems like it
seems like the media and just the
general population of the country even
if even if cait's rates are going up and
death rates are going up it doesn't
really seem to hit home with a lot of
people you know if you don't lose the
left one or something like that so as
case even if case rates do keep spiking
and going up and as states continue to
open do you see down the line in the
November election
if we have it on time maybe Trump
gaining ground is gaining approval with
his denial you know of that there's
actually a problem and maybe red states
will be flourishing a little bit more
and if we keep it under you know who
keep hospitals from capsizing over their
limits yeah good okay very very good
question so there's there's two ways
that this could go now let me make clear
I would love it I would genuinely love
it if all of these red states that open
up don't see a resurgence I would love
what do you see that it doesn't happen
and that things just go great and then
blue states can open up and then
everything's lovely and then we go and
hopefully we remove Donald Trump in
November anyway but your question is a
good one which is if the numbers do keep
getting worse in these red states and
it's already happening to some degree
it's happening in Texas it's happening
in Georgia Tennessee is increasingly a
disaster etc I think in the short term
Trump's strategy will work which is
normalize it pretend everything's fine
okay I mean yeah some people are dying
but this is the new norm it's status quo
I think it'll work for four weeks six
weeks maybe eight weeks but when it
continues and then you also get the
disastrous second quarter GDP numbers in
August I don't think it's going to work
for Donald Trump to just keep insisting
everything's fine I I don't I think it's
a short-term play if by chance there are
no resurgence --is grim opening I'll be
happy because I don't want there to be
but it will work out for Trump to some
degree otherwise I think it eventually
will completely backfire on him yeah do
you know the limits where you know
they're at least functioning yeah yeah
all right my friend very great I
appreciate the phone call thank you so
much